Le succès de notre algorithme VQE dépend beaucoup
de l'état et du circuit
que nous choisissons au départ.
Je suis Victoria Lipinska et dans cette vidéo
nous allons explorer les options
que nous avons pour les concevoir.
Examinons de plus près
tous les éléments
que nous avons à chaque exécution de la partie
quantique du VQE.
Nous commençons par l'état de référence,
parfois appelé état initial.
Nous faisons passer l'état de référence
à travers un circuit paramétrisé appelé
forme variationnelle
avec un choix initial de paramètres,
et nous mesurons l'état
dans la base du Hamiltonien
après l'avoir fait passer à travers le circuit
pour obtenir la valeur espérée. Maintenant
nous allons parcourir chacun de ces éléments,
en commençant par l'état de référence.
Un choix typique pour l'état de référence
est l'état zéro.
C'est l'état dans lequel un ordinateur
quantique est déjà initialisé.
Pour les problèmes de chimie quantique,
on peut aussi utiliser ce qu'on appelle
l'état Hartree-Fock,
qui est le résultat d'une
méthode Hartree-Fock.
En un mot, la théorie Hartree-Fock
donne un moyen simple de construire
l'état de référence en approximant
l'état fondamental d'un système quantique.
Elle trouve une rotation
dans l'espace des états
qui minimise l'énergie de l'état fondamental.
Enfin, l'état de référence
peut aussi être très spécifique au problème,
et tu pourrais vouloir choisir
un état personnalisé.
Dans le cas où tu sais quelles propriétés
ton système possède, par exemple des symétries
ou un nombre spécifique d'électrons
dans l'état, tu peux utiliser cela
pour avoir une meilleure convergence de l'algorithme
VQE.
Choisir un bon état de référence
est important pour la convergence
les états de référence proches de
l'état fondamental
peuvent rendre le problème converger
beaucoup plus facilement et rapidement.
De même, le choix des valeurs de paramètres initiaux
est tout aussi important
que nous introduisons dans la forme variationnelle.
Par conséquent, selon l'état de référence
et les paramètres initiaux,
nous pouvons converger rapidement, lentement
ou pas du tout.
Regardons ce graphique
et pour des raisons de visualisation,
imaginons que notre espace de paramètres
n'ait qu'un seul paramètre.
Un très bon état de référence
peut te permettre de commencer très près
de l'état fondamental final
et la convergence sera rapide.
En revanche, si tu commences très loin
de l'état fondamental ici,
état de référence
a, tu devras traverser une haute barrière d'énergie
menant à une convergence très lente
ou à aucune convergence du tout.
Nous aborderons cela plus en profondeur
dans le module d'optimisation classique
de ce cours.
Regardons maintenant le circuit paramétrisé
qui agit sur l'état de référence, alias
la forme variationnelle.
Quand ce circuit, le U de thêta agit sur la référence
état,
il produit ce que nous appelons un état d'essai
psi de thêta ou parfois ansatz.
C'est cet état ansatz qui est
ensuite mesuré dans une base appropriée
pour obtenir la valeur espérée
de l'énergie.
Les formes variationnelles
dont nous parlons ici
WEBVTT
sont motivées par la chimie.
Cependant, garde à l'esprit
qu'il y en a aussi d'inspirées
par l'apprentissage automatique quantique
et d'autres algorithmes
à court terme comme les algorithmes
d'optimisation approximative quantique.
Parlons de quelques choix courants
pour un ansatz de chimie.
Le cluster couplé unitaire ou UCC
est la méthode proposée à l'origine
dans la première publication VQE,
et elle est couramment utilisée dans les problèmes
de chimie quantique.
En général,
lorsque nous paramétrons un état quantique,
nous travaillons avec un nombre
exponentiel de paramètres.
Cependant, pour rendre les circuits
de préparation efficaces,
nous avons besoin d'un nombre polynomial
d'opérations
et donc d'un nombre polynomial
de paramètres.
UCC est un exemple de façon de préparer
un état d'essai avec un tel circuit
et il dérive d'une méthode
de cluster couplé,
qui est la référence absolue
en chimie quantique.
Le choix le plus courant est le cluster
couplé unitaire
simples et doubles
ansatz ou UCCSD en abrégé.
Parce que UCCSD est motivé par une
configuration électronique spécifique d'un problème,
nous devons nous assurer d'avoir un état de référence
qui reflète correctement le système.
C'est l'état Hartree-Fock.
L'ansatz UCCSD donne généralement
une bonne approximation de l'état fondamental
parce qu'il capture les excitations électroniques
simples et doubles dans une molécule donnée.
Le nombre de paramètres dans UCCSD évolue
quadratiquement avec le nombre
d'orbitales de spin.
UCCSD peut être très bien
adapté à un problème,
mais malheureusement, la mise à l'échelle
quadratique conduit encore à des circuits très profonds
qui sont difficiles pour les ordinateurs
quantiques actuels.
C'est pourquoi les chercheurs d'IBM ont proposé
une approche plus heuristique,
où on peut adapter une forme variationnelle
au matériel sous-jacent
ce qui donne un circuit
exécutable efficacement.
C'est-à-dire que les états d'essai sont paramétrisés
par des gates quantiques
et sont adaptés
au dispositif physique disponible.
C'est une approche très heuristique
qui est adaptée au matériel.
En nous basant sur ces exemples, examinons
le spectre des possibilités
que nous avons pour exprimer
notre forme variationnelle.
Beaucoup de celles-ci
sont déjà implémentées dans Qiskit
alors je t'encourage à essayer par toi-même
laquelle est la plus adaptée
au problème que tu essaies de résoudre.
Si nous regardons le graphique, d'un côté
nous avons les formes variationnelles
très heuristiques.
Quand la spécificité du problème est faible, mais
elles sont conçues pour être implémentées
sur le matériel réel.
Elles sont aussi très expressives,
dans le sens
qu'on peut exprimer
de nombreux états quantiques avec elles.
Cependant,
un problème qui peut survenir dans la phase ultérieure
d'optimisation classique
est de rencontrer
ce qu'on appelle le plateau stérile,
dont nous parlerons dans le prochain module.
D'un autre côté,
nous avons le cluster couplé unitaire hautement spécifique au problème
qui fonctionne
excellemment en chimie classique mais
WEBVTT
est difficile à implémenter sur le
matériel quantique à cause des grandes profondeurs de circuit.
En général, les calculs
peuvent être plus réussis si tu peux,
premièrement choisir un état de référence
et un ensemble initial de paramètres
qui créent un état ansatz
proche de l'état fondamental.
Et deuxièmement, éviter les paramètres inutiles.
Ceux-ci introduisent soit
une plus grande profondeur de circuit sans bénéfice
ou créent un espace de paramètres plus grand
à explorer menant à des plateaux
dans l'optimisation classique.
La question de savoir quels paramètres sont nécessaires est un problème
spécifique
qui nécessite une réflexion approfondie.
Parlons de l'endroit où notre invité d'honneur,
le Hamiltonien, se cache dans tout cela.
Comme nous l'avons appris dans la section précédente,
le Hamiltonien après le mappage qubit
est représenté comme une somme de
chaînes pondérées d'opérateurs de Pauli.
Au final, cependant,
nous voulons évaluer la valeur espérée
de notre Hamiltonien sur l'état ansatz
produit par la forme variationnelle.
Heureusement, la mécanique
quantique est agréable et linéaire
et c'est ce que nous utiliserons
pour obtenir la valeur espérée.
Voici comment cela fonctionne.
Nous savons que le Hamiltonien est une somme pondérée
de Paulis
grâce à la linéarité,
la valeur espérée de la somme
est égale à la somme des valeurs espérées
de chaque chaîne de Pauli.
C'est formidable parce que comme tu le sais déjà,
mesurer dans la base de Pauli
est aussi simple qu'une rotation
de la base de mesure standard.
Au lieu de mesurer la valeur espérée
sur ce grand Hamiltonien représenté
comme une somme, nous évaluons d'abord les valeurs espérées
des termes individuels
et les sommons à la fin
avec les poids correspondants.
C'est pourquoi dans de nombreuses ressources
tu verras seulement des rotations sur qubit unique
après l'ansatz.
C'est ce qui implémente le Hamiltonien
à chaque exécution du circuit.
Dans la prochaine vidéo,
nous explorerons ce qui se passe
lors de l'étape d'optimisation classique.
À bientôt.